islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can
uh my name is ali as you guys know um so
as you guys guys might remember i did a
reaction video uh to you i actually did
a real video to yourself um i'm a muslim
yeah have you
have you ever read the quran or come
across islam uh i i study history so i
love history so i know a lot about the
middle east i've been to the middle east
and i love it it's always very welcoming
and very accepting that's good can you
tell us a bit about yourself like for
example i've seen your videos etc yeah
um but firstly uh your name uh so i'm
ollie london i'm a k-pop singer uh tick
tocker and youtuber as well okay so how
would you happen to refer to you ah just
whatever just
oh jimin jimin okay i think about jimin
okay i'm gonna call
when did you start this
um so i actually started making kpop
music two years ago um i used to live in
korea and i fell in love with the korean
culture so my producer one day made me a
song it's like okay you're doing this
song i was like really me of all people
and i'd always love kpop so it's like
okay let me try and then i released the
song it did very well online so i've
actually now got to the stage where i've
just released an album uh fallen angel
and today i'm dressed up to film my
christmas and career video okay so is
this the music video that you're doing
that you've been going around yeah so
this is um just a christmas video just a
fun one for the fans to get everyone in
the christmas spirit and to get everyone
happy yeah just just a question from
like a perspective as a muslim what do
you think would you say is your life
purpose in life what is it something
that you would like to achieve or would
you see your purpose of life
for me i just want to find happiness but
also spread happiness to others so i
always believe in spreading positivity i
like to make people laugh i like to
entertain people um especially when we
have the pandemic it's a very tough time
for the world so i like to give people a
bit of light entertainment online and
also spread kpop and korean culture as
well okay so when we talk about
happiness like for example
how do we attain happiness for example
what do you would you say is something
that makes you happy because when we
attach our safe self to materialistic
things anything that we attach our heart
to be a relationship be a partner be it
material things when that thing leaves
our happiness leaves with it so would
you say
that maybe in your life what has caused
you unhappiness and how did you seek
happiness i just think that when i was
younger i never liked the way i looked
and i used to get bullied at school so
that gave me a lot of unhappiness but
since i've obviously changed i've had
some surgeries it's given me so much
confidence and happiness and it's it's
given me a new lease of life so but i
feel like you know we do find happiness
from within so it's not just an external
it's not just our appearance or like you
said material things don't mean anything
true happiness is feeling love feeling
happy feeling positive and that's you
know it's very hard we all have a quest
to find happiness and we don't always
find it so it's yeah as muslims for
example we are told in the quran that
god almighty says it's only in the
remembrance of god that hearts truly
find peace so what it is is that
connection to the higher being the
higher power and understanding our
purpose because i'll be honest with you
when i was young for example like i was
not happy with the way my nose looked
right yeah okay so now i did get what
was those societal pressures and other
elements that was making me feel as if i
am not attractive now when i was young
for example obviously i was like oh my
gosh should i get a nose surgery or
whatever it may be but as i grew a bit
older and i came back i'm a river to
islam i accepted islam about nine years
ago i
i realized to myself that i had a lot of
slave masters and what these when i'm
slave masters what i meant was like
materialism money the opposite gender
how i looked to be pleasing to them and
i felt like hold on a second these are
actually my masters and the only way i
can free myself from them is to find
please the one who created me because
he's
and be happy with who i am because i
believe if i'm happy with who i am i
don't think i can be happy with who i
become that changes it it depends on
person to person but i found it to
happen is by trying to please that one
that created me because i realized that
the things that i'm trying to be a
master to are never going to be happy
with me so that's where i found it so
would you say for example
you're at a stage now
that you are fully happy is there any
other for example like maybe
adjustments that you would want to make
to yourself why would you say i'm in a
place where i'm like okay you're very
right it's very hard to get to that
point tonight you said there's a lot of
things around us that influence us and
influence our happiness but i've got to
a stage now where i'm super happy with
my music career with my look i'm getting
more of the jimmy look um but i'll be
super happy when i live in korea so that
will give me the ultimate happiness so
that's the next step but i've got to a
stage now where i'm super happy i love
my life i feel very grateful i feel very
appreciative and
you know material things don't really
matter because it just makes me realize
as you get older it's like you have to
appreciate the people in the world the
animals and you know spread happiness
yeah i would would you mind if i give
you a gift of the quran
before i just give i know because you
need to go i want to hold you up anymore
can you open it in a random verse and
let's see what maybe message they might
be yeah
any page and pointer of this okay
and i'll read it for you uh
oh yeah which verse
uh pick a verse let's okay 52 52 let me
okay let's read okay we go
so do not okay so do you know do not
obey the disbelievers here and strive
against them with the great striving
yeah so this is talking about the quran
so what is talking about you know when
the prophet muhammad came with the
message the the pagan arabs didn't like
it and they were persecuting him just
because he was striving with the quran
so let's just carry on and he it is who
um has released simultaneously the two
seas one fresh
and one sort of utter and he plays
between them a barrier and prohibition
partition and it is he who has created
uh from water so we believe every living
thing is created from water the human
being
yes
and marriage and ever is your lord
competent but they worship rather than
allah that which does not befit him that
them or harm them and the disbelievers
are ever against their law so this is
what you're talking about in a nutshell
is that the main message of islam and
why it came down was that we free
ourselves from the shackles because
there was a philosopher he said man is
born free but in shackles everywhere
yeah we all have restrictions exactly so
the reason the quran islam came down was
to free mankind from all the shackles in
society be it money be it people having
to be even bullied that was really sad
like nobody should be bullied and made
you feel
kindness and happiness you know there's
very important teachings in the quran of
course exactly
and say i do not ask for you for any
payment only whatever will to make so
god saying he doesn't want any money
from you he just wants you to have a
connection with him i'm sorry
do you believe in a higher power by the
way i'm atheist but i do you know i
appreciate all this no problem do me a
favor do me a favor yeah just try it no
i'll read it
when you go home just say god if you're
there guide me i would say jimin
if you're there
but this is a great this is one who
created jimin
thank you very much actually i would
organize this uh thing we tried we
didn't want to really uh intrude on them
as doing a music video etc whatever it
may be uh but was interesting and i
think what really touched me there
dawood is his last statement um because
he wants to be you know jimin is a
korean pop star okay
so he wants to be like him and look like
him
and i said to him i don't know if you
heard of it when you go home pray to god
he said i will ask jimin yeah and i was
like this is the one who created you
yeah but the thing is that
it goes back to
um
foundation because what you're doing is
in a nutshell i don't mean intention
unintentionally but he has made jimin
his i i i do and i mean i'm not talking
about pop star literal worship that he
wants to look like him and i mean this
in a way but i don't want him to watch
this and feel like we had a very nice
discussion um it's just that it seems as
if that is is some kind of deity
sometimes you know i and i feel like him
he seems like a very warm and nice time
person
but i feel like sometimes people look
for things which we within them but
outside exactly because the fingers were
all created to worship god yeah it's
either you do that or you substitute and
try to substitute that yeah i don't
think it was nice this question guys
hope you enjoyed it um and once again
yes and we asked allah to guide him and
myself and we should never belittle
judge people i didn't want to come here
and be hostile allah whoever he wants to
get it and subhanallah we should make
dua for him that will subhanallah guides
him and accepts islam inshallah